Senator James Lankford of Oklahoma is
one of 13 Republican senators asking the
Justice Department to pause the
separation of families while Congress
works on a solution he's inside the US
Capitol for an interview you'll see only
on CBS this morning
senator good morning good morning I know
you have joined some of your Republican
colleagues in asking the Attorney
General Jeff Sessions to move on this
immediately is it your understanding
that the Attorney General could change
this with a stroke of a pen I do think
he could change it with a stroke of the
pen it was a stroke of the pen that
actually changed to this it could change
back on it the issue is do we allow
individuals to be able to choose
volunteer return keep the family
together while they're making a decision
if they choose voluntary return then
they could return back before charges
are actually filed what's called the
Flores settlement where it separates
families and forcibly separates families
due to that settlement only kicks in
once charges have been filed so our
request is just to lay when you're
filing charges give the families time to
be able to make a decision if they're
not seeking asylum they were trying to
be able to cross the border illegally
then they're given that opportunity to
be returned as a family now I know
senators don't just sign petitions and
letters you also pick up the phone have
you spoken with the Justice Department
have you spoken with the Attorney
General of directly about this I have
actually spoken with the Secretary of d8
they excuse me of DHS secretary Nielsen
she and I've had a good conversation
about this as they're trying to be
working together the default position I
believe should be that families stay
together and that's that's the default
there should be exceptions to that as
there always have been but the default
is family stay together
what about asylum seekers who don't come
in through ports of entry senator what
would happen to them so that that is a
bigger challenge asylum seekers should
seek asylum at a port of entry that's
the spot that people if they know
they're gonna request asylum they can go
they're not violating a law secretary
Neilson has been very clear that if
you're seeking asylum go to a port of
entry
don't try to illegally cross the border
in the open area and then once you get
into the country then declare asylum
because it makes it much more
complicated for people they don't know
whether you're seeking asylum where
you're trying to illegally cross the
challenges at that point they have to
get people to a spot to be able to
determine if they qualify quickly for
asylum and then make the decision from
there and it slows down the process
dramatically so it sounds like you're
you're talking about wouldn't change the
family separation with asylum seekers
but let me ask you a question quickly
about ms-13 you're on the Homeland
Security Committee the president has
said these family separations are
necessary to protect against ms-13 is
there any evidence you've seen anywhere
ever that families have ms-13 members is
a part of them when they're separated
not that I have seen there is a very
real threat of ms-13 moving to the
country and what we've typically seen as
unaccompanied minors when they're coming
the country once they get a placement
and there's somewhere in the country
waiting on a nose to appear or waiting
on some kind of adjudication that they
get scooped up by people that may be
ms-13 already in the country and try to
recruit the men that is a very real
threat and we do have a very real threat
of individuals crossing our border that
have terrorist and terrorism connections
and other human trafficking connections
so it is a tough complicated area but
just to be clear that's a totally
separate issue from these families yes
sir
have you heard anything senator about
where the girls are being held we've
been asking we were in Texas for the
past couple of days it's been asked
repeatedly we're not getting any answers
about where the girls and the young
younger children are being held do you
have any answer about that I do not have
an answer directly HHS well getting
clarity from HHS right now has been
tough they've been very quiet about how
they're doing processing but I don't
mean to look back on this but the
President Obama when we had the surge of
unaccompanied minors coming in 2014 they
put up several facilities very quickly
military bases and other spots to be
able to put unaccompanied minors we were
not allowed access to those locations
unannounced either
and there was a lot of challenges at
that point where HHS was working with
individual contractors they'll put in
facilities I do think and I have shared
with the administration as much
transparency as possible helps everyone
to be able to get answers to questions
and to be able to look at it we are a
government of the people by the people
for the people that people want to be
able to get basic answers and that's a
very reasonable request all right
senator Lankford thanks so much for
being with us sure thank you